aaron rodgers would never admit this but
i'll go ahead and say it
other than the obvious you know physical
differences like he's got real skill and
i don't
i think he and i are a lot alike mike
florio i mean don't waste your time
reading uh reading crap like that no i
know what makes him tick
mike florio i mean don't waste your time
reading uh
reading crap like that i think we'd have
a hell of a time after he beat me up
mike florio i mean don't waste your time
reading uh
reading crap like yes
yes i have anything else to say no
that's it that's it don't waste your
time reading don't waste your time
reading crap like that
thank you aaron rodgers i still chris i
still believe that he and i would get
along really well
i do a lot more we have a lot more in
common than we than we don't have in
common all right
uh one thing we may not have in common
he probably doesn't regard the packers
as the 14th best team heading into the
season but this more
from my standpoint is a reflection of
what the packers did
or didn't do in the draft that they're
on the cusp here they are and they've
invited this dysfunction
by trading up in round one to disrespect
aaron rodgers they can paint it however
they want
they've disrespected aaron rodgers by
drafting his replacement
while he's made it clear he plans to
play into his 40s and he wants to retire
with the packers and how do you
reconcile that with
trading up in round one to draft another
quarterback when you still have
aaron rodgers under contract for four
more years at one of the most lucrative
contracts in the nfl
to me this decision by the packers to
consciously take a step back
in the hopes of becoming a team that can
compete with the 49ers down the road
they're basically throwing in the towel
this year and next year i feel like
they're trying to build something where
they think they can compete with the
49ers later so fine if you're going to
take a step back
i'm going to give you a step back and
i'm going to drop you down in the
ranking
of the various teams well i mean i i get
it i think you're going a little low
with them here as far as like 14 for a
team that got in the final four
but i got my concerns a little i mean
here we are yeah it's 20 20.
and we're back into like oh man it's all
on aaron rodgers to make it happen on
the offense
you know listen i like aaron jones i
understand he's talented
there's no doubt you know is he a
superstar is he in that top five running
back conversation
no not in my opinion not yet i mean i'd
like to see
like another year of real good play
before i throw him in there
yeah and then you talk about the draft
and everything like that and the free
agency
you know they get one guy devin funchus
he's not there
oh so it's back to rogers and devonte
adams hey aaron you know bail us out
hopefully that run game can continue to
grow there you know but they lost a
bulaga
uh so there's there's it's a weird it's
a weird feel for a team that went to the
final four last year i don't really know
how to explain it
i guess the the best way to look at it
is going like
you know if you're not getting better
you're getting worse
you know and they're they're one of
those teams where i want to be like yeah
the off season they kind of just stayed
the same
and i don't know if that's really like
you know a term of
endearment going into the following
season so
we'll see where it goes from here
here's my comparison for the 2019 green
bay packers i'm going to go back one
year earlier to the 2018
chargers you brought this up last week
the philip rivers quote from last summer
that the chargers who were 12 and 4 and
20 18
easily could have been six and ten yeah
i feel like the packers
who were 13-3 in 2019 easily could have
been a lot worse than that
close games that they found a way to win
they had a couple of losses in
california
where they got exposed and then came the
championship game in
california where they got really exposed
and i think they got rattled i think
that shook them to the core i think
the organization looked at 13-3 and said
what did it ultimately get us it got us
an ass kicking by the 49ers
that's why i think they've taken this
step back they haven't gotten
immediately better
even though it would have been easy to
do it aaron rodgers recently said
hey when they traded up in round one i
thought they were making a move for one
of these receivers
he thought he was going to have that new
weapon across from devonta adams
in the passing game that's the logical
thing to do yeah that's the thing you do
if you're trying to supersede the 49ers
but i think that that smothering that
they endured with the bob grizzy passing
performance from jimmy garoppolo where
he hardly threw what eight passes i
think it was for the game
i think that was so demoralizing to the
entire organization
they've decided to a certain extent to
rip it down
and try to build it back up in the image
of something that operates more like
what the 49ers do chris
so yeah let's get into it go go ahead
you got any thoughts on that before we
move on yeah well i mean
first off your point you know yeah 13
and three it was one of the more
underwhelming 13 and threes we've ever
seen
and they were eight and one and one
score games wait wait why were they
eight and one and one score games hold
on
hold on it's coming to me oh that's
right cause they have aaron
freaking rogers so oh just do it again
aaron
it's okay don't worry you know and yes
you know okay their defense i like a lot
of their defense
but there is a flaw as we saw in those
you know three west coast trips two of
them to san francisco
where they got absolutely bludgeoned in
the run game
so that is like concerning to me too
yeah you got kenny clark
you know but who else on the interior
part of the defense is is worthy of
talking about
the secondary i like you jai air
alexander the safeties are awesome
i like the pass rushers on the edge we
know that's good
but when they had to play teams that had
big offensive linemen and can run it
down their throat last year
people ran it down their throat and that
worries me
when you're also asking the quarterback
on the other side to always save the day
and win by one scorer or do whatever
so um you know that that's my answer to
that i don't know mike what do you think
best case worst case where are you going
well let's hang on for that because we
got a couple of things to get to before
we get the best case worst case
what's more likely aaron rodgers winning
the mvp
or leaving the packers after this season
what's more likely i'm gonna say mvp
i don't think he's gonna leave after
this season because i just think jordan
love is that raw so i'm gonna go mvp out
of those two choices
yeah and i'm rooting for him to be the
mvp i know aaron you may you may find
that hard to believe i like a good story
like this i always root for a good story
and there's no story better than maybe
both right
aaron wins the mvp and the super bowl
mvp
and then he walks up to mark murphy with
the super bowl trophy like
paul crew from the original longest yard
hands it to murphy and says
stick this in your trophy case and walks
away
and he moves on somewhere else and good
luck with jordan love speaking of jordan
love what's more likely he gets a taste
some hill package of plays
or he sits on the bench all season i
think uh sits on the bench all season
long
you know you know one he's not a taysom
hill type guy taysom hill was a
basically a glorified college running
back who learned how to throw the
football
you know if this is they drafted this
guy in the first round protect him for
the future
let him learn his way and just learn
under aaron rodgers
all right matt lafleur also added to the
team this year in round two another
running back
aj dillon over the weekend leflore was
asked about the physique
of aj dillon here's what leflore had to
say
i'm just wondering have you ever seen
legs like aj dylan
on a running back and uh is your calf
anywhere getting close to back to
compare with his oh come on man you're
gonna make me look bad
uh no my calf looks extremely weak
but uh was out there in shorts but aj
dillon he has got some massive
legs and we you know we that's something
that we talked about with our staff we
have not seen a running back
built like that not not in my career
that i've ever been around
chris you gotta love that oh you've got
to love that you're mr legs and butt and
aj dillon my god
that picture scared me it's unreal and i
saw it in person last year doing the
notre dame game boston college came to
notre dame and
trust me it's every bit as impressive as
it is in that picture
i mean he is uh i mean a greek god the
way he's built
250 pounds you know like a legarrette
blunt
but you know more ripped and it looks
like he lifts weights more and does that
that way so i mean yeah that's gonna be
a great combination
i love those type of combinations
there's aaron jones he's fast he's quick
he can shoot through a hole you're used
to chasing him and then all of a sudden
late in the third quarter
you go what i got to tackle this
bulldozer now i'm like tired i don't
want to tackle this guy
uh so i think that can be a very
effective effective combination
i remember when the giants tried to do
tiki barber and ron dane thunder and
lightning remember that 20 years ago and
it took him to the super bowl
all right best case worst case what do
you got uh
best case you know i don't know the nfc
north
there's it's up for grabs so best case
yeah of course
they can win the nfc north i don't think
there's anybody there to look at and go
oh
you know i don't know the best player in
the division still number 12 in green
bay
so i give them and they got a lot of
other good players on the team still
and they know how to win football games
and they're battle tested so i don't
think they can win like a first round
bye
number one seed i don't think that's
happening but i think they can win the
division
worst case i can't see it again i'm not
trying to cop
out but with aaron rodgers a quarterback
i don't see worse than eight and eight
i don't you know they could be crappy
and i still think he can pull you know
a horseshoe and a rabbit out of his butt
a handful of times to keep them right at
500.
i think best case is a division
championship not
anything close to a one seed right and
their their best outcome is to have what
happened last year happen this year i
think
go to the nfc championship game if
everything falls your way
and get and and get handily beaten by
the san francisco 49ers
worst case though i could see the wheels
come off
and here's here's one of the big reasons
why mark murphy said over the weekend
that they had more than 80 percent of
their season ticket holders opt out for
this year so they decided
for the first couple of home games no
fans at all lambeau field without fans
that's going to be a weird place for the
packers to play
i mean every time you see a game on tv
coming from lambeau field it's raucous
it's loud it's the go pack
go it's the whole atmosphere you take
the fans out of that atmosphere i think
the packers are going to be a little
wobbly those first couple of home games
they play for their first six on the
road they could get off to a bad start
you could have some dysfunction brewing
within that organization because one
thing that i think teams
learned the hard way when you go 13-3
and you have that special season
and it comes crashing down you go back
to zero and zero yeah
you you you start losing games early and
you start comparing it to last year
i think you start getting real nervous
you do about everything's falling apart
and i think it and i think it could
no i think you're right mike you know
you you start to you know you start out
one and two you're oh man
what's wrong with this why don't we have
the magic of last year what are we doing
what
is it you know and yeah the panic button
can be hit there in a hurry and you're
right them playing
on the road early on you know it's
sneaky tough schedule
uh it's a team that's very very
interesting this year but they're
fortunate
and they're in a division that i don't
think we can look at one team and go oh
they're dominant i feel like all the
teams are very
close and similar and have some big
questions throughout the nfc north
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports